hello everyone
welcome to
rational science
but today i'm not transmitting from
germany i'm in south america
and i had a little bit of trouble
with the um with my internet over here i
hope everybody can hear me fine
let me know otherwise uh in the comments
there in the chat okay so if you can
hear me
and see me fine i really appreciate some
back feedback on that okay
anyways meanwhile i'll continue
i'm going to be covering a little bit of
extinction first and then i'm going to
move on to physics we had some issues
brought up on the issue of
homosexuality okay so let me talk about
that a little bit here we had a fellow
he says
there are selective pressures
for the males too and when those change
you get consequences in the case of
dimorphism as it
related to competition between the
genders keep in mind that men
are no longer fighting to survive
against enemies in hand-to-hand combat
or predators and animals in the wild
okay thank you
uh assuming those were pressures that
contributed to the evolution of strength
and power in males when those pressures
are gone you're likely to end up with
softer men
that don't even have good coordination
or aggressiveness
okay this alone might allow women to
catch up
okay
so i guess it's an arms race
and when there is no race because you
don't have to fight against the element
i guess that's what he's saying then
there is no reason for women not to
catch up to men
i don't know if everybody agrees with
that but uh i guess that's one point of
view
okay
okay here's another fella he talks about
testosterone whether you need it or not
to
to overcome or overpower women okay
says i think i read a theory at some
point about
less testosterone leading to less
conflict
i wonder how the level of testosterone
and modern men compared to hundreds of
thousands of years ago again an issue of
evolution whether we develop more and
more
uh
or at least we used a lot of
testosterone in the past because of
different uh environment that we were in
and that we don't need that anymore
today because we don't have to fight
against the element we we are the kings
of the mountain so to speak right we
have nothing to fear
okay
okay another fella says
if i can get him up here
says all human embryos uh start the same
kind of as women but then eventually the
gonads or something else starts making
testosterone and other other androgens
and this leads to major changes not only
in the reproductive organs but the whole
brain wiring
i suppose that the more testosterone at
that stage the more wiring gets altered
um yeah the question is whether
testosterone is the deciding factor okay
whether
if uh
if you have more estrogen or more
testosterone does that make any
difference
i mean you have again women who have um
primarily
obviously estrogen and you know they get
in the ring they can beat up some men
out there so i mean i'm not sure that's
got in as much to do with testosterone
and estrogen as it has to do with skill
and strength and so on
and you will find females which are
pretty strong
and they have estrogen so
i don't know
uh
the jury's still out on that one that i
guess was the main point that i was
trying to make last time whether
estrogen and testosterone really have
anything to do with strength
remember that
in the animal kingdom in general you
know females that have estrogen and
males have
testosterone but
again there's it's the social factor the
fact the the roles that each uh
member of the like lion clan or the
hyena clan have that maybe decides who
has what skills and not so much the
chemical composition inside the body
another vowel says
says
uh i think it's a combination of both
he was talking about whether it's nature
or nurture
uh don't know if it's more nature or
nurture though i believe straightness is
the standard simply because it's what
works to keep the species going
not because sex feels good
or any of those those are secondary says
right reasons but it is mainly because
it's simply practical
all homosexual people they like it or
not come from straight human
relationships there are physically no
other ways
well yeah i mean you know homosexuals
obviously come from
uh
heterosexual couples
uh i don't think you can get them from
homosexual uh couples and uh
but then the question is how much
uh nature and how much nurture there is
and if there's any
nurture at all
i can only give you my five cents worth
and that's um that i think people are
born gay i don't think
they are educated to be gay i don't
think you can undo what you have inside
you
and just like heterosexual people don't
fall in love with their own uh types
i don't think in in the same way that a
homosexual can change his
orientation he's born with it i think
he's hardwired that way and again i
showed uh last time that
there's several studies
one by this fellow swab
and he's uh dutch
and what he did he took some brains
and dead people and he looked at the
sizes of the
that
dimorphism
[Music]
i can't remember what it was the
gland or whatever and he found that
there were differences between
homosexuals and heterosexual men
so
i think there is a physical difference
between them and that's something if
you're going to be do
looking at this subject you should do
some research on that i also read uh in
the past couple papers
that sheep
also have that issue where
uh the
males that are
uh homosexual you know they put like 10
sheep in a row
and they have them there in their stalls
and here comes
they bring the sheep they suspect of
being homosexual well they bring several
sheep but they they figured out that the
ones that always
you know they can smell all all the
sheep there and they go after the males
and those are the homosexual ones
and approximately 10 percent of sheep
are
deemed to be homosexual
and when they look at the brains of
these sheep
more or less like uh what schwab found
there that
you know the brains have differences
so it's up for you to ponder if you're
going to be doing research on the
subject
okay uh i still i hope i'm still alive
here
uh
i still am getting uh that they're not
receiving uh enough streaming on youtube
can everybody hear me can anyone confirm
that for me
okay because i just got a yellow uh sign
there from uh
youtube
again i'm in south america i'm hope i'm
hoping everybody can hear me
still okay
i don't know i don't know why i got that
message from youtube okay so please bear
with me i'm worried about being you know
losing contact anyways final issue uh
here it is
um fellow says what about human survival
through meal worms he's talking about
the extinction of man
and he says we mealworms can eat just
about anything and we can eat mealworms
and if you look up what is a meal worm
what's the larvae uh form of the
mealworm beetle
what is he talking about he's talking
about maggots
that's what he's talking about whether
they're flies or
yeah thank you thank you for the
confirmation anyways uh you know are we
going to be eating maggots that's the
first issue the second issue is that
you know if you look up meal worms the
they uh
they uh you know they can eat apples
they can eat stuff like that but the
question is whether they can eat some
weeds that nobody wants
you know so the diet of the of the worms
is one issue then the other one is what
are you gonna have a uh
a farm a a maggot farm just grow maggots
and eat them is that what it is
you know i don't know if that's much of
a future it might help you survive your
group or you
but it's not going to last several
generations so
even if we survive or some pockets of
humans survive eating meal worms or any
kind of maggot
i don't think it's got
very much of a future
okay
okay let's move on to
physics we're going to be talking about
uh mass and weight today primarily
weight that's the issue today what is
weight
and what i'm going to be doing here is
starting out with a comment that someone
made okay uh related to my previous um
presentation my previous lecture says
the following the pro the quotes from
aristotle you present clearly are
talking about densities it takes more
force to push an object through water
than it does through air and less force
if the air is thinner if these quotes
he also says that it takes in these
quotes he also says that it takes more
force to move a heavier object which we
know is also true gravity is different
from of course because the force of
gravity is proportional to the weight
these quotes don't mention gravity or
falling at all so this claim about uh
iron balls falling seems to be entirely
strong and created by someone else with
extraordinarily poor reading
comprehension or maybe you simply
presented the wrong quotes i don't know
much about aristotle's writings well the
the issue is uh yeah maybe i didn't make
that clear uh i was not talking really
about gravity i was talking about force
and i was talking really about
aristotle's uh reasoning
his reasoning was that
um
you have some resistance to flow
if you move through water you move a
little
harder than if you move through air that
sort of sort of thing
and he applied that to gravity i didn't
quote the gravity passages from his book
what i was saying what i was referring
to was what was his reasoning process
okay why he concluded that uh you know a
heavier object uh falls faster than a
slower one because he carried out this
type of reasoning he was looking at what
resistance
that object encounters okay so that was
the the context i just want to clarify
that if that wasn't clear the first time
okay let's move on here here i'm going
to begin with a review of mathematical
physics
okay of
how they look at weight
specifically okay and i'm going to start
with force which is what i ended up with
last time
and here you have it
i was talking about force equals mass
times acceleration which is newton's
second law of motion
and i'm saying that's a push
force that's a force of push primarily
because you're talking about where the
object departs
to where it ends and what do we mean by
that well it's being pushed now you can
say well maybe it's being pulled from
the front but they never justified that
because there is no pull from the front
except like if you're pulling on a
donkey with a with a rope and in that
case it's still a push because what's
really
pushing
is the rope on the back of the donkey's
neck so it's still a push force okay
so uh i'm saying that force equals mass
times acceleration is a force of push
exclusively
and on the other hand the uh
newton's gravitational law okay which is
that second one there force equals
gravitational constant g
mass one times mass two divided by
distance squared i'm saying that's a
pull force
okay and
uh i don't know if they ever discovered
that they don't
they don't talk about in terms of push
and pull they just say well this one's
the gravitational law and that one's the
second law of motion that's all they say
okay they apply it
okay what is mass according to the
standard
you know the uh worldly wisdom
quantity of matter and that's
essentially how mathematical physics
treats it it says quantity of matter
that's it okay that's the notion uh what
is weight summarizing
pull or push of gravity
could be
push right it could be pushed from above
but they always talk about the pull of
gravity keep that in mind okay
weight uh then is i guess you could say
a push under the
uh quantum mechanics notion because you
you have all these particles that are
allegedly pushing the object downwards
towards the earth if you're going to do
it particles i'm not sure how you can
pull with by throwing particles from the
center of the earth to you right
and that's one issue the other one is
when you have a general relativity what
you have is warpage of space-time
well somehow that
what you're doing is like in the case of
a planet earth or the sun it's pushing
the canvas downwards that's the notion
they have and then the whatever object
could be a photon could be an electron
could be an atom is rolling down that
inclined plane
that's the notion they have okay so it
is a push
no matter what okay
the question is why would the photon or
the electron or whatever you want to
throw into that hole why would it roll
downwards
what's pulling it down there or is
something pushing that downwards
and that's for you to figure out but my
point is that the original warpage of
space is created through a push
mechanism that's the point okay so what
do they say well they say well if you
have the same mass okay
and you weigh differently in different
parts of the universe like if if your
mass here on earth is a hundred
kilograms you would weigh only 16.5
kilograms on the moon
okay
and they really have no explanation for
that
what they use is mathematical
description they say it is so
you go you weigh here 100 kilograms you
go to the moon you weigh a little less
right and
you can prove it with uh
astronauts going out there great
what have we learned we have a
description but we don't have a
mechanism are they being pulled towards
the center of the earth are they being
pulled to the center of the moon
or are they being pushed by i don't know
particles coming from outer space
what's the mechanism okay
and we do have a mechanism on a
mechanism under the rope model
and here it is okay
okay here you have it if you have uh a
bigger object such as in this case the
earth okay as you can see it's a little
bigger than the moon okay
and so there there's a lot more ropes
connecting every atom on earth to one
atom of the astronaut it's tied to that
foot of his in this case in this example
and there are a lot fewer atoms on the
moon and they're pulling on that same
atom but there are since there are fewer
atoms you have fewer ropes
in fact fewer um
independent ropes that's what we call
them because they have to be pulling in
or really it's attention but we'll call
use the word pull forward to sacred
argument what i'm saying is that you
have fewer ropes acting okay in the case
of the moon because there are fewer
atoms on the moon that comprise the moon
than the earth very simple
straightforward kindergarten stuff okay
you don't need to know any more than
that
uh so so we have a solution for for why
that's the case why you're being uh
pulled more towards the center of the
earth than you are being pulled towards
the uh the center of the moon
okay so uh you might say well
what's pulling i mean you know uh how do
you know there are ropes that are
pulling on each atom of your body
okay so now we introduce a little
evidence okay
people like evidence they want proof
okay so let's introduce some of that we
don't go for proven evidence in rational
science but a lot of people say prove it
to me bill okay let's prove it
let's move in
let's go with that here's mr uh richard
muller he's a professor at berkeley
i think he still is
i don't think he retired yet and he says
for example if you have the earth
there's a big mass here you bring to the
earth right and you have you with your
little mass here that's you there a
little
uh
drawing of a human on top of the earth
the big mass and the little mass okay
every atom on the earth is pulling on
every atom of you
let me repeat that every atom on earth
on the earth is pulling on every atom of
you
richard muller not me okay that's what
he says
you're also pulling on it
okay the amazing thing about gravity is
that it goes right through things
okay
so
how do you pull on every atom on earth
and how do you get gravity to go right
through things right through walls
you know you have a you have an
astronaut he's in outer space and he
wants to bring uh create this gravity
shield he wants to protect himself from
gravity so gravity doesn't touch him so
he puts a shield in front of him and it
turns out that the earth attracts the
shield and attracts him right through
the shield
both of them
and the moon and whatever's behind him
how do you do that
unless every atom in your body is
connected to every atom on earth that's
what master mueller is saying
okay that's the theory so we have a way
of showing that and essentially you know
that newton's uh gravitational law is uh
sound it's consistent with the rope
model no problem there okay
now how about uh the establishment well
for that we have to go to uh the word
weight what do we mean by weight okay
let's find out uh this is the official
version by the way okay here we go
uh wait you look it up this is from the
wikipedia wait the force acting on the
object due to gravity
okay
and there you have the uh simple
equation weight equal mass
times
gravity in this case the gravity on
earth which is 9.8 meters per second
squared okay that's the graph that's the
acceleration of gravity okay
represented by the letter g little
letter g
okay but then we find out that there are
a little bit of some problems here okay
and it's got to do with the definition
that's the official definition now we go
to all the fine print
okay some standard textbooks define
weight as a vector quantity
the gravitational force acting on the
object others define weight as a scalar
quantity
the magnitude of the gravitational force
yet others
define it as the magnitude of the
reaction force exerted on a body by
mechanisms that counteract the effects
of gravity
now how's that we have at least three
notions three definitions
three descriptions of what
weight is and just in case it says
further complications in elucidating the
various concepts of weight have to do
with the theory of relativity according
to which gravity is modeled as a
consequence of the curvature of space
time
guess who came up with that one
the current situation is that a multiple
set of concepts co-exist
so we start off on the wrong foot
because we already have all these at
least four definitions there are four
notions of what weight is
and the mathematicians don't care they
you know they they use this stuff they
don't care about the qualitative stuff
so they could care less they can live
with the stuff okay
uh
anyways you see it it says weight equal
mass times the acceleration of gravity
that little g there where did they get
this
let's find out okay here we have it
give me a second here
okay
they get it from force equals mass times
acceleration newton's second law okay of
motion which is uh a push
um mechanism
and if you turn that around
you know you play around with that you
get mass equals force divided by
acceleration okay now this is a math
course here i'm trying to just get the
notion the qualitative notions out of
this okay we're not going to be doing
numbers or anything like that here
okay so you can see acceleration is a
dynamic concept all three of them all
three variables there are dynamic
concept velocity is the dynamic concept
time is a dynamic concept and so is
acceleration
so they're talking about motion here
okay and yeah force had better have
motion because force above all is
directional whether you push or pull
the the donkey has to move one inch at
least in one direction or the other
okay keep that in mind
force means you got to move you can't
stay in there same location that's my
point
okay so we look at well okay what is
that velocity well velocity includes
speed what is speed you move a little
higher there and says speed is equal to
distance divided by time
but what's the problem there that
distance is not distance
not in mathematics
in physics yeah distance is is this the
separation here we're talking about
distance traveled
again it's a dynamic concept so they're
talking about displacement of some kind
some motion
but
if you want to have velocity
that's not enough to have speed which is
just distance traveled divided by time
you need one key issue which is
direction
you can't do velocity without direction
and that's
uh quite um
in line with the word force because
force is motion in a given direction so
we're okay there okay
where's the problem well the problem is
weight
is location specific
weight carries no motion
okay let me repeat that
you have a given weight only for a given
location somewhere in the universe
you change your location your weight
changed
so weight is location specific there is
no motion but here they're talking about
using newton's second law of motion
which is what a law of motion meaning
he's going to move from location to the
other
so the question is whether they can use
this equation force equals mass times
acceleration to calculate weight
is this
the uh
equation of weight
well you you saw that weight included
the uh
gravity on earth the little g
acceleration of gravity that's that
acceleration there
but you need the earth you need a second
object
so we're not talking about one object
moving towards the earth we're talking
about two objects and we're talking
about location we're not talking about
acceleration or motion or anything like
that or distance traveled you're talking
about separation
so you can't use this equation this
equation is the wrong equation to use
for weight
you can't use it because this is dynamic
equation for force
okay
and here you see it okay this is perhaps
the equation we should be using we
should be using
newton's gravitational equation okay so
we should replace that force equals mass
times acceleration for weight equals
mass times the acceleration of gravity
with
force equal at least as a starting point
right force equals the gravitational
constant g mass 1 mass 2 divided by
distance squared now that is a
gravitational equation and that's what
weight is wasn't it defined as a
gravitational phenomena
okay
and i'm going to argue further that this
is not even any equation of force it's
an equation of tension
tension is not a force force is not a
tension
there's only two forms of contact we
call force and that's push and pull
tension no one wins the tug of war okay
let me illustrate that here
okay no one wins the tug of force uh the
tug of war uh during tension
and the problem is that you know what
they've done over the years is define
tension as a pull
force
that's what everybody thinks it is so
they always pull it un put put it under
the word pull
they think it's a force of pull of some
kind because one guy is pulling against
the other that's the way they look at it
it's not
because tension
is like if you hold a stick
made of a single piece because you're
frozen in time there is no motion you
have a single frame in the universal
movie and that's what tension is that's
what weight is and that's what newton's
equation is
because you know that that changes
according to distance what distance is
it the distance traveled no it's the
separation between two objects what two
objects mass one mass two
that's what the equation tells you
qualitatively
okay
and uh here you see the difference
between force and tension okay
these are the definitions you see force
and influence that when can do what
change
change
the motion of an object
if you change the motion what you've
done is change locations because motion
is two or more locations of an object so
when you have motion you change location
once you once you change location you do
have force
okay force can also be described i like
the word that they use described
intuitively as a push or pull
push means you change locations
pull means you change location whichever
one you use doesn't matter you change
location a force has both magnitude and
what direction
okay
weight does not have direction
it really doesn't it it is a tension
between two objects there is no motion
you don't know which direction it's
going to move
it's just a static situation that's a a
static predicament okay
tension is what
well this is their definition okay by
the way the pulling force transmitted
actually along an axis right in by the
means of a string a cable chain or
similar object
okay
so all i'm saying is uh they use the
word pull because they're thinking that
tension is the stretching you're
stretching stretchy stretch you're
you're stretching the rubber band so to
speak
and it wouldn't matter if you stretch a
string or a rope or whatever but think
of it as something that's being
stretched that's what they think of it
so they think it's changing
locations
uh gazillions of seconds by gazillions
of seconds
so they think they're stretching
something no that
that's not tension
what tension is
tension is a tie game nobody wins the
tug of war okay so it's a tight game no
there is no motion under tension
attention is a static concept
okay so
let's move on here
this is the definition of the word mass
now keep that in mind okay we're going
to compare mass against weight we
already looked at way we're saying
weight has no motion whatsoever what is
mass in comparison well you start out by
saying in mathematical physics one may
distinguish con conceptually between at
least seven different aspects of mass
seven different notions that they have
of mass there are a number of ways that
mass can be what
measured or operationally defined
what is an operational or functional
definition
it's an irrational definition because
it's an after the fact definition you do
an experiment you do an observation and
that is what retroactively was your
definition with you started out your
presentation that's that's what an
operational definition is and they're
talking about measurement we're not
talking about measurement we don't care
how you measure mass we want to know
what mass is what is the definition of
mass
and here you have a couple examples six
of them inertial mass
uh active gravitational mass what is
that a measure of the strength of an
object's gravitational flux
passive gravitational mass is a measure
of the strength of an object's
interaction with a what gravitational
field sounds like weight doesn't it
energy also has mass according to the
principle of mass energy equivalence mr
einstein there you know
e equals m c squared curvature of space
time is a relativistic manifestation of
the existence of mass
and finally quantum mass manifests
itself as a difference between an
object's quantum frequency and its wave
number
so so which one of these should we use i
mean here we have six notions of mass
they're telling you there's seven
notions of mass i can tell you two off
the top of my head one is relativistic
mass which they use in special
relativity and that goes against what
inertial mass so you have inertial mass
on the one hand you have relativistic
mass on the other and what is
relativistic mass well it means that if
you move faster and faster almost at the
speed of light
you gain mass
and if mass is the quantity of matter i
guess you're gaining atoms
as you go faster and faster is that what
it is or are you pressing
stronger and stronger
harder and harder against the scale
sounds like weight
so is there a difference between weight
and mass
it looks like there ain't because you
know here you have this relativistic
mass and all you're doing is pushing
against something which they say well
your mass increases surely you're not
increasing the quantity of matter in
your body what you're doing is pressing
down harder because of your speed
against the scale that's what you're
doing
so yeah uh looks like they're confusing
mass with um with weight okay and yeah
there is no difference unless someone
can show me that if you take something
to the moon right
and they say well the the mass stays the
same what change was the weight
well how do you know that if the way you
determine mass is not by counting atoms
which would be quantity of matter now
the way you do it you put it on a scale
of some kind and you weigh it
and you end up with so many kilograms
and how do you measure your weight don't
you measure it in kilograms also
so i don't know what the difference is
maybe someone can tell me someone can
clarify that in in very precise ways not
a one-liner because certainly you won't
do it with that okay
and here we look at the differences here
it says mass is both a property of a
physical body
uh what are they referring to it looks
like they're referring to the quantity
of matter right
and a measure of its resistance to
acceleration
which sounds a lot like weight when you
look at the acceleration of gravity
okay so again we don't see any
difference there and if it's quantity of
matter what do we do we count little
uh atoms of how much the table is made
a gazillion atoms is that how we do it
or do we weigh it
okay mass measured in what kilograms
refers to an intrinsic property of an
object i thought we weighed our weights
also in kilograms i mean when they ask
me
i don't tell them in what it says next
their weight measured in what newton's
measures and objects resistance
well i don't know i don't weigh my
i don't give my weight in newtons i
never have i always give it in kilograms
which is what mass and if you weigh
the mass
then all you're doing is uh you're not
telling me how much matter it has
you're insinuating that but you're not
you haven't counted atoms i mean if mass
is the quantity of matters you would say
well bill weighs one gazillion atoms
then
or has a mass of one gazillion atoms
then we would understand it because that
would be quantity of matter but if you
say one kilogram or 10 kilograms 100
kilograms now you're not talking about
you know anymore about
counting atoms quantity of matter now
you're you're giving your your value
in a measurement instead of in counting
counting and measuring are two different
things counting you count apples measure
you measure a table
those are not two
not the s not identical ways of
determining something okay so again you
know they determine master weight and
then they say but they're different why
are they different because on the moon
you weigh differently well how do you
know if uh
or your weight is different but your
mass is the same well how do you know
the mass is the same if you're going to
determine mass through weight by weight
by putting it on a scale so this is the
issue it's it's a circular argument
because they have never been able
since the days of newton to determine
the difference between mass and weight
they define it differently they give you
the run around but they cannot put their
finger on it they can't show you what
the difference is
and the reason again is that they don't
count
quantity of matter ever they never have
they never will because nobody's going
to take the trouble counting every atom
in the
legrand kilo for example
okay which is the original standard that
we had for the kilogram
okay i just want to confirm that yes
mass is the quantity of matter here is
evidence proof what people want out
there okay here you have it
mass is a measure of the amount of
matter in a substance or an object flex
books mass as quantity of matter a uh
the paper in publication meant
confused you
bet mass is the quantity of matter in a
body regardless of its volume or of any
forces acting on it the term should not
be confused with what with weight which
is the measure of the force of gravity
acting on a body how it works uh daily
wherever you go i mean you don't have to
take these you go just google it and
find out what mass is and you'll find
out that a lot of people just most of
people out there think of it as the
quantity of matter what is quantity of
matter you count apples
that's what quantity of matter is you
got 100 apples that's quantity
if you're going to measure how much they
weigh 100 apples away now you're giving
me the weight
and they say well it's the mass so what
is weight well mass and weight are the
same because what we're measuring it
against the gravitational the
gravitation of the earth
they're way different on the moon yeah
they weigh different on the moon did you
count how many apples you had
i mean yeah you can say well those same
apples like i still have 100 apples but
they weigh different on the moon yeah we
do that with apples
now do that with i don't know the grand
kilo do it with a human body do it with
an astronaut then we'll know that you
you're on the right track
okay here's the summary of the
conclusions
no definitions of mass or weight the
impact what did i show four definitions
of weight seven definitions of mass
so what we we take our pick we we get to
pick which one we want
is that what it is
uh so other than that mass is equal to
weight because they have never been able
to isolate mass from weight
by the way i i think it was newton who
created the first guy who
separated mass from weight in his
principia i don't know if there was a
previous precedent okay
but he's the guy who i think separated
them but again you know it's just a
mathematical
uh trickery just a
maneuver
yeah you go in there and you say mass is
this weight is that and this is how we
determine this and how we determine that
that's all it is just a bunch of
definitions but
they can't they can't make them count
because again
we don't count mass we don't count the
number of apples
tension is not a force why because it
doesn't meet the definition of the word
force force is motion tension is no
motion think of it as a
rod made of a single piece separating
two objects
you take a snapshot of that that's
tension tension means no one wins the
tug of war you have a single frame of
the universal movie cross-section of
time if you will
and what you have is think of it as a
single piece
okay so you have two objects like a
dumbbell okay and dumbbell made of a
single piece that's it that's tension
tension there is no motion in either way
supposedly because they're under tension
you know in tension they think well
they're pulling okay so if you pull
something that can stretch no longer
now it's under complete tension the most
tension that you can think of
now what's now what's moving
now nothing's moving now the rubber band
is stretched to the maximum limit
and so now you have tension complete
tension 100 tension there is no motion
within that rubber band
so tension you have to think of it as a
single piece rod that separates two
objects
newton's gravitational equation force
equals
gravitational constant mass 1 mass 2
divided by distance squared is about
tension and not about force
that's a tension equation okay because
weight is location specific at a given
distance from in this case the earth
the the
the astronaut is i don't know 100 miles
from the earth you take a snapshot of
that that's his weight at that location
he moves a millimeter he has a different
weight
period we're done because that's what
the equation says not because that's
what bill says
that's the equation tells you that
newton's gravitational equation what is
it pull
why because it's the separation between
two objects it's mass one versus vast
mass two divided by what
separation that distance there is the
sep the qualitative separation between
two objects and newton's second law
which is the force equals mass times
acceleration that's a force of push why
because you're gonna have motion that's
a not only do you have motion but you
have something else you have direction
it's moving in a given direction
force
newton's second law is a vector
it got magnitude and direction
that's not the case with the
gravitational law
okay
okay
uh we had some questions from last week
last time i saw you
i was on a trip
and i'm not not uh getting high or
anything like that i mean i was on
vacation trying to move around okay
here's the first one
father says pseudoscience he brings the
subject of pseudoscience good subject to
discuss yeah there are uh pseudoscience
uh there are irrational theories out
there we that's what we called it and um
uh here's some examples uh irrational
theories particle at two places at once
how's that for an irrational theory
uh big bang creationism uh
something comes out of nothing
uh
don't tell me about it just explain it
to me give me the mechanism how does
something come out of nothing
even in this case even without god we
got rid of god in big bang remember
god doesn't exist there it's just big
bang is just the explosion of matter
and space by the way and space very
important and space from
nothing i don't know because space is
nothing but you figure it out
black hole zero dimensional singularity
that pulls
on
stars that are gazillions of miles away
and what's the mechanism again
irrational theories and dark matter
the
what is it the galactic
problem a rotational problem what is it
that uh they had to
sprinkle all this dark matter on the
outside of a galaxy to maintain the
integrity of the galaxy
yeah i mean i could sprinkle little
stars there as well you know let's bring
the fairy godmother and she
uh you know moves her wand around
creates this magic sprinkles dark matter
around the galaxy
all these are irrational theories
and then they have irrational terms uh
why because none of these are defined
first of all but then even worse they
use these concepts and they reify them
turn them into objects energy
and they turn it into mass which which
is actually another concept but
it's like they're saying this this fog
that's out here this cloud this mist
suddenly turns into a rock
that's the notion they want to give you
but both energy and mass are concepts
okay and energy has not been defined and
mr richard feynman's nobel prize in 1965
he said it very clearly we have no idea
what energy is now how's that for a
definition
field what's a field well you know a
field is out there where you play
football right that's called a field
i don't know of any other field that's
physical other than that you have a
gravitational field in the uh electrical
field uh a uh magnetic field okay
and
those are concepts what is a field field
is defined as a bunch of numbers that uh
around ground zero that's it that's what
it is a bunch of numbers that get weaker
uh as you get away from ground zero
and that's concept and so when the the
problem is they turn that word
into a physical object they start using
it as an object
in the case of waves there which the
field is associated with the transverse
wave you know maxwell's transverse wave
what you have is vectors
what is a vector magnitude and direction
they put a little indian arrow in there
but that indian arrow represents
magnitude and direction and those are
concepts and you have all these arrows
they're moving sideways very very
scary stuff you know i mean you have all
this magnitude all these fives and sixes
they're moving
you know
sometimes when i'm drunk it happens you
know perhaps
and uh that's what a wave is what is the
wave what's waving we don't know it's
just a wave of vectors
particle uh i put it in there because
the particle i'm referring to the
quantum particle uh
what is that it's a zero dimensional
point particle
so called point particle and what is
that that's a nothing
but it is a collapse of the
of the wave function that's what it is
so when you look at the word particle
you have to think of this mathematical
thing this this function that collapses
is that a physical object
and that's what how they use it vortex
what is a tornado of what what's what's
vortessing
what's moving around what's tornadoing
that's what you gotta identify tornado
we all know what it is i mean it's a
bunch of air that's moving in circles no
problem there because air is made out of
atoms
but here what's up what's this vortex
uh ether bunch of particles that are
uh waving up and down i guess to create
light
either it's just a bunch of particles
that's a concept a bunch of particles
are not a physical object okay an object
is that what you can point to
in a static image that's not what ether
is
so yeah
that's the first problem then here you
have the second problem okay uh
pseudoscience so the definitions any of
various methods theories of or systems
as astrology mathematical physics or
clairvoyance consider it considered as
having no scientific basis
and i guess we're going to include all
of mathematical physics in there
pseudoscience consists of what
statements beliefs or practices that
claim to be both scientific and factual
but are incompatible with the scientific
method absolutely mathematical physics
none of it is
compatible with scientific method
because uh the explanations they give
you the theories are all irrational so
you know all of mathematical physics
falls under
pseudoscience not not a single piece of
it survives
and uh here says pseudoscience is often
characterized by contradictory
exaggerated or
unfalsifiable claims i got a problem
with uh unfalsifiable because that's
popper's criterion karl popper austrian
philosopher and the problem i've got
there is that unfalsifiable is by whom
by the pope
dalai lama who who unfolds who falsifies
it
i mean
you might think it was falsified to you
what's true to you is false to me and
vice versa
so falsifiable is not a very good
criterion to
determine what science is and continue
says reliance on confirmation bias again
that's confirmation means opinion rather
than rigorous attempts at refutation
again opinion i don't this is not about
reputation it's about understanding a
theory
lack of openness to evaluation by other
experts
experts i didn't know there were
authorities in science
uh who's the expert plato uh maybe
galileo
newton are they the experts
absence of systematic practices when
developing hypothesis okay and continued
adherence long after the
pseudo-scientific hypothesis have been
experimentally discredited sounds like
mathematical physics i mean these people
continue with white space uh particles
at two places at once even after all
that has been discredited you can't even
imagine it so how can it be credited how
can it be
uh proven or
non-refuted okay
the term pseudoscience is often
considered pejorative particularly by
purveyors of it because it suggests
something is being presented in science
inaccurately or even deceptively
man that's a full description of
mathematical physics right there
okay here we have uh
the issue of cult
i think the saint fellow brought up the
word a particular system of religious
worship
ah
that certainly sounds like uh general
relativity certainly sounds like quantum
mechanics especially with reference to
its rights and ceremonies well there you
have the examples uh we have space time
for general relativity point particle
or quantum mechanics
uh rights and ceremonies you get the
nobel prize the templeton prize the wolf
prize
what is all that
those are ceremonies those are beauty
contests you get a little crown on your
head you walk with your bouquet of roses
down to the catwalk is that what it's
all about
an instance of great veneration of a
person ideal or thing especially is
manifested by a body of admirers
okay i guess they're talking about plato
isaac newton albert einstein nicola
tesla is that who they're referring to i
mean a lot of people worship these names
you talk about anytime i mean you can't
even touch the name of einstein that's
what these people talk about they
worship him
so i guess you know all that falls on
their
cult and finally a group having a sacred
ideology and a set of rights centering
around this their sacred symbols well
you have black hole everybody worships
the black hole the standard model all
the particles
none of them you never see a single
picture of a single particle but it's
already taken for granted it's the it's
the cross right the one you pray to of
um
uh quantum mechanics object of uh
mathematical physics you have some
people who believe in sacred geometry
sacred
what the hell is that now that's cult
that's what it's known as a cult yeah
so uh yeah just be aware that there are
people who try to bamboozle you with
some of these
pseudo sciences
and they form cults and
the cults
have have become religions now because
you have these major they were cults a
long time ago now they're they become
religions they they've uh incorporated a
lot of these things and now it's just
part of the catechism it's part of their
um indoctrination
so you go to
colleges
and this is what they give you
they they just read you the party line
that's what you're supposed to memorize
if you want a degree
and if you buck the trend
you're going to be in a lot of trouble
because you don't get your degree you
won't even get an advisor
okay again another fella says
if strings produce the tensile pull
force also known as gravity have you
explained how they produce the push
force that keeps objects apart
he's talking about the rope okay here's
the rope
and so
he's saying you know uh
how do you produce i guess push with a
rope
well we have to start at the beginning
because here he's got several errors
okay so let's go with the errors first
okay the first one is strings what the
hell he's talking about
maybe string theory
you know we're talking about ropes here
and uh we
defined the rope quite well we said we
described i mean we show the rope it's a
two
strand
coiled
rope
pair of strands and they're not strings
that's the first one so this fella
hasn't done much of a research on the
case if he's going to use the word
strings i don't know what he's referring
to then he talks about tensile pull
force well i just covered that uh tense
it tension is not a force okay it's and
certainly it's not a pull okay tension
means nobody wins the
tug of war okay so tension is not a four
so correct them there and only two
forces push and pull that's all the ones
we know of and tension is not a pull
and uh then no such force as tension
okay and this is the context the context
is that you can't pull with particles
can you imagine pulling with those
particles there i mean here you have a
cross section of time everything's
uh god has essentially stopped
everything from moving how do you get
that to move
do you get one atom to move at a time is
that what you do one particle to move at
a time
and with pull you have you have this
situation let's connect all those little
dots okay all those little particles
we're going to assume they're atoms and
here we connected them
okay so they're all connected now
now you can imagine
not only at first you can imagine pull
you can imagine action at a distance but
it turns out that you know when one um
one of those atoms moves and hits
another atom well then you're going to
have your push force you're going to
have atom against atoms surface against
surface
so there is no problem in the under the
uh
under the rope model for that
and let me just uh say the following you
can also push with a rope not that it is
uh
part of this um context here okay
but here it is let me show you this
here you have
a rope
and you can do this at home always in
the presence of a trained relativist
okay
so you torque the rope
and here at the end you're going to feel
a
push a little thump against whatever is
connected to this end so you can torque
the rope whenever you torque there's
always this this uh
motion in which you feel a thump there
and so the the uh
rope does
um
produce a push of some kind remember
we're talking about something very very
tiny very very thin that connects two
atoms you can't even see or
touch that thing but
you can do it with a torsion you you
when you torque something it does create
that uh some kind of motion there that
you can uh
easily identify as push but the point
here is that first with the rope you can
produce action at a distance and when
the objects come together they push each
other away or merge sometimes so
we have no problem with push
it's the particle that has problems with
pull that's where the problem is
okay another issue fellow says renee is
right referring to renee descartes okay
there is no such thing called empty
space this fell saying that okay
there can be no space without substance
descartes would probably agree with him
there is no such thing as empty space
but when he included that second portion
that second statement there there can be
no space without substance now we run
into trouble okay that's not what
descartes said but this is what this
fellow understood
now there you have space with substance
and space without substance
okay
so uh
there you you have the
the comparison so there is a space
without substance what what is that that
black stuff that nothingness
there's no object there there's no
particle there there's no rope there
there's nothing there it could be
between two galaxies a region that has
no matter whatsoever no ropes crossing
specifically in a given
portion of space but more important than
that
you need to have space to give a
backdrop a background to whatever object
you have even to the rope even to the
particles of quantum mechanics how do
you understand particles without some
contrast and here let me show you what
i'm talking about here's a good old god
okay first let's go with him
and here's god in space and god without
space i mean if uh
if if you remove all space i guess god
is infinite is a single block of what in
this case a black block
you need you need to provide contour or
backdrop to god in order to see god okay
and so here here you have my analysis
space is not a thing
that's the first one we have to talk
about and exist only refers to that
which is
which are things you can't have a
non-thing existing okay so you can't
talk about the existence of space the
existence of nothing no such monster
okay thing that which has shaped space
nothing right synonym of nothing that's
what doesn't which doesn't okay
nothing does not need something
that's the one i want to clarify to this
fellow okay
nothing does not exist with or without
something
okay it's the some things that can exist
not the nothings
and then um
god needs space okay he needs a little
bit of space give him a little room okay
god is nothing without
okay if you remove nothing
god is nothing he's a single block of
whatever because it's the space that
gives him contour okay and let me give
you another example here this is the
ether the famous ether what is ether a
bunch of particles that's what it is
okay
what happens if we remove the black
stuff what if we have what happens if we
remove the space the nothingness well
this is what you would get
how's that for
removing space
yeah it's space that provides the
contour to each particle otherwise you
know uh you would have a single block of
flat a white or a block an infinite one
you would have i guess nothing i don't
know what that is
so this is the issue these people
um
want to give you the notion
that uh you can have
uh
you cannot have space without something
in it and that's not true your space is
something different than than the
something that nothing is different than
the than the uh something you can't
confuse those two and say well one can't
live without the other well the objects
cannot live without space that's for
sure now can space live without
objects
uh i would say yeah
space can live without object i think
there there has to be space out there
that is not crisscrossed by ropes that
is not
occupied by objects by uh particles and
it's very simple to figure that out
there can't be that because every
particle has to be contoured you have to
have a backdrop to conceptualize the
word particle
or the thing we call particle
you can't have a particle without
something contouring and what are you
going to contour it with another
particle well what separates the two
particles what is that dividing line if
not space what's contouring each
particle that's the question you have to
answer
okay
okay uh final issue i think here uh some
phel says
all casual influence is transmitted by
direct contact between material entities
correct i agree there are you talking
about wendy strings oh my god
no no wendy strange belongs to strength
theory we have 1d nothing there is no
such thing as 1d object a 1d object is
one that
the mathematicians invented and they're
not even referring to object when they
talk about 1d one dimensional they're
talking about an itinerary that is a
straight line that's what they're
talking about or maybe
it could be a um
what is it a uh what do you call
geodesic which is a curved
curved straight line if you want to
think of it that way it curves through
the fourth dimension i guess or in in
our dimension our three-dimensional
world it's a curve and in the fourth
dimension it's a straight line which
means it's not either a straight line or
anything like that it's an itinerary
that is curved around the earth around a
sphere and they say the fourth dimension
is a straight line or straight itinerary
you figure it out a displacement anyways
from the so-called the strength here
yeah
again this felt is confusing string
theory and what you're seeing there
those little strings they call they say
well those are one-dimensional strings
again no such monster because every one
of those little lines that you see there
is at least two-dimensional that's the
first issue the second one is that they
say that that thing there somehow
vibrates as it's expanding and
contracting there and what it does is
what you're staring at are supposedly
particles of quantum mechanics
primarily what the graviton because
that's the one that string theory is
concerned with so what you're staring at
there are not strings the the word
string is very misleading okay because
you're thinking of some physical object
and there are no such thing as physical
objects in mathematical physics physics
with quotations again there are no such
things as math as uh
things
what they have are equations they're not
interested in explanations or mechanisms
which require objects obviously for
physical interpretations they're talking
about descriptions and they're talking
about
the motion of objects and how you
describe them mathematically that's what
mathematical physics is into so you hear
the word string and you say oh they're
talking about some kind of very tiny
very thin string now they're not they're
talking about an itinerary of a particle
that's what they analyze at the
universities or all these think tanks
that are are out there what they're
doing is analyzing motion fellas
okay there are no such thing as strings
in string theory
and with that i'll see you on sunday if
everything goes well and i hope
i got through to everybody was